a la crítica situación ocurrida en la
cárcel de guayaquil ecuador se sumó un
nuevo drama el de los familiares que
sufren la angustia por desconocer el
estado de sus allegados internos usted
ya encontró su familiar
algunos familiares reclaman que se
expedite la entrega de los cuerpos
todos tocados 500 muertos no me lo van a
dejar vivos pero tengo un cajón
con una centena de cadáveres por
identificar las autoridades instalaron
mesas de trabajo en un coliseo de la
ciudad donde los familiares solicitan
información y asisten al proceso de
identificación de los cuerpos mientras
se preguntan cómo pudo haber sucedido
esta matanza la ms con nosotros vamos a
la visita nos revisan todo lo mínimo lo
revista lo hacen hasta desnudar y no sé
cómo entran todas las armas todas están
armados
tras la declaratoria del estado de
emergencia carcelaria las autoridades
emprendieron minuciosos registros con la
finalidad de desarmar a la población de
internos y evitar que un suceso así se
repita